okay i'm going to open
open the subcommittee work session on
house bill 1192 relative to the board of
acupuncture licensing
and relative to the qualifications for
licensure as an acupuncturist
and i handed out um anyway so i learned
wednesday afternoon i got a call from
representative schmidt
who had spoken with um i don't have the
name offhand but whoever chairs the
acupuncturist
board
that
there's a senate bill senate bill 282
which was
dealt with acupuncture but then they
amended it
and i've passed out the amendment
replacing the entire bill with this
amendment
and it ends up dealing with the same
issues that we were trying to deal with
in 1192.
and um
oh sorry i forgot that representative
grota wasn't i'll start over again
um
are they in the office is there yeah are
they sitting out there yeah i should
i know i i was going to
give you the overview i wanted her to
hear
but we can discuss it it looks like the
amendment is a almost carbon copy of our
bill is that is that right um well it
it deals with one issue that we didn't
which is who gets or that i don't recall
being in ours maybe it is
who gets to call themselves
an acupuncturist and under what
circumstance you can advertise as a you
you can't advertise as a physician or
doctor unless you actually have a doctor
as a doctorate of acupuncture or
something
but the bulk of it is dealing with the
requirements for licensure and renewal
and um
so i i also got a phone call from um one
of the
two ladies here who from uh you know the
accu the actual punctuators who
were two of the top ones in the state
and um
she told me that the acupuncturists in
general were completely happy with this
um and you know if you like we can look
through it and discuss it
i had only one section i had maybe some
question about
but
what i'm i think i'm going to propose is
that we retain this and carol mcguire
has been involved in the discussion
that we retain it
and uh see what the senate does and
you know if
in any way if the senate and by the way
senate bill 282
um with the men with amendment is
actually on the senate consent calendar
for the next time they meet
so the committee's already voted out
otpa unanimously
so i expect it to come out of the senate
i expect it'll come back to this
committee anyway
so we'll have a chance to look it over
in detail if we want
um but i don't see any point in
proceeding with 1192. do you have a
you yeah mr chair it's this is not the
only time that a bill has followed
parallel tracks in the house and the
senate and and and i would say it's not
over until it's over and that what the
senate does is what the senate does and
we should pay no attention to that we
should make this bill what we think it
ought to be i would be perfectly
amenable to our amending it to be
identical to senate bill 282 and then at
the end of the day uh they'll decide
which one becomes law and it won't
really matter
i'm not opposed to that um the only
thing i'd say it's not an early bill
and so we can if we want hold on to it
as it is and then decide to amend it or
whatever we want to do i don't have a
problem with delaying executing the bill
until later in the session
but i think to to basically sending it
to interim study just because it's not
identical governing is not not a
viable option right i'm not um
i didn't make myself clear i'm not
suggesting interim study or even formal
retain but just the committee hold on to
the bill for now but that would be fine
would you like someone to prepare an
amendment to make it identical to
sure you're welcome to do that i'll be
glad to take care of that okay um
before we do that could we just have a
chance to look at both of them i'd like
to look at it and certainly so
and actually i had one section and i
only had a chance to read this amendment
first i think yesterday evening either
um yeah if anybody
i had a couple questions one on
the second page starting at you know
section twos and three
where it's naming not so much two but
three
where um
visual license so yeah issue a license
to one who satisfies and reach the agent
majority
they added or equivalent certification
approval to the active ncc aom
certification and i know the
acupuncturist had an issue with that
organization
left the fee amount to oplc which is
good
one difference is that they uh in our
bill we have license sure by passing the
kale exam um and in the senate bill they
left that out uh but there's the option
for
uh equivalent certification approved by
the board so they could adopt that same
process the rule making i i don't see
that as being a substantial difference
right i agree i think
you know
putting too much in the way of specific
organizations or standards becomes a
problem for the future as things change
so
i think i mean i looked it over last
night and a little bit today i don't off
i do think that
well i'm not sure how do we do we have
to before
the end of the period or house period
before crossover
do we have to make a formal
recommendation to retain the bill
until the next until we receive the
senate bill i don't think we can
i don't think we can retain the bill in
the second year
um you know someone can correct me if
i'm i'm wrong about that but
we do have to vote out some
recommendation right
and i think the options would be you
know ought to pass our tasks with
amendment itl maybe interim study
um
i think we will see before crossover
what the senate does
i think their my understanding is
they're going to have a session the same
week we do
and so we'll see the results at that
point
so boogie's going to hold on to the bill
until we see the senate bill
and then we can if we need to amend the
senate bill or accept it as is right
right i mean that's my suggestion we'll
get we'll get sb 282 assuming the senate
passes it which looks like it'll come to
us anyway
and then we'll have 1192 as well if
there's some reason we feel we need to
do something with it
so but don't we have to report at 1192
before crossover and we get the senate
bill after crossover um
we will the senate will have voted on
the bill before crossover
they will have voted um i believe the
that we're doing the votes on the early
bills right so the week of
the 15th somewhere in there when we have
session i believe they are as well that
week
and they'll have voted then
you know whether or not to
pass this otpa
and we'll know that
at that point
now whether
formally the bills before this committee
at that point i don't i don't know you
know i think we do actually we can't
actually get bills before crossover the
but at least we'll know and if if it
looks like the senate did something
wonky we can decide to move forward with
1192 at that point
well the deadline for i'm looking at the
deadlines for the house calendars
and this bill is not going to a second
committee right so we're not the
deadline is february 24th to act on
house bills not going to the house
committee
um
let me see if i'm
see if i'm misunderstanding something
here
no that thurs the 24th is the last day
to act on house bills going to a second
committee so that's the deadline for the
house to act on i'm so sorry i was
reading last it's march it's march
right
well that's the act to report march
march 10th is the last day of the report
so that's for the committee to report
on bills not in a second committee so we
have until march 10th right
right to do something with 1192 and i
you know if we're completely happy with
282 and the senate passes it i mean we
could
itl or interim study or whatever it
seems appropriate with 1192 but if not
we can amend it and
recommend it
we can also just pass an amendment
identical to senate bill 282 and let the
senate decide which one they're going to
let become law
i i don't that's usually what has been
done in other committees that i've yeah
i mean i'll leave that up to the chair
um
as far as i'm concerned i'm fine either
way
so does anybody have an objection to
just recommending to the committee that
we hold on to this bill
until um
the senate acts on 282 and then decide
what we want to do
okay no issues with that okay great and
and in the meantime i'll prepare an
amendment as you suggested so that we
can make it identical to 282 and then we
have that in our pocket right and if for
some reason which i don't expect some
somebody finds some problem with the
amendment to 282 we can always redo it
okay i'm going to close the work session
and i will open it for the work session
for house bill 1563
requiring state employees to be enrolled
and
i don't have strong thoughts on this one
i've had several conversations with
people
and it's funny because there are people
who have no opinion about it at all
people who think it's a good idea and
people who don't think it's a good idea
and people who don't think it's a good
idea is because they think that there
are other
plans that people could get into
that would be better than than the
government one
so and what this plan does it doesn't
prevent them from doing that the only
really difference in the plan is that
you have to opt out of the plan as
opposed to opting in
and
is that perceived as a mandate i guess
that's the that's the word that i
i guess thrown around and i i
particularly don't like that word but
um i don't know what else you know what
other term to call it but i would say
that thirty percent of the people that
i've spoken with
are in that category and the other 60
are in the great idea or i really don't
care idea group so
that's the feedback i've i've sort of
taken a poll of different
age groups and different political
affiliations and
it's really sort of uh
maybe something people haven't also
thought about before
yep
okay thank you anybody else
yeah my question is whether this bill is
even necessary because people can enroll
in this plan at this point in time i do
have an issue with automatically
enrolling people in this because people
don't always pay attention
if we were to amend line six change
automatically enrolled to offer
enrollment
uh i would be totally good with that but
i'm not sure that the bill is necessary
right i think that if that's
that amending it that way would make it
completely unnecessary because i i would
imagine that this is offered along with
all the other benefits when somebody's
employed as
as an option um
so they're probably presented with it
anyway i mean
as i said i don't have strong feelings
on this i understand what
what representative mcguire and the
others were trying to do
it's um
to change the default so people who
aren't thinking about it are more likely
to
save for their future than not
and i have mixed feelings on that i
understand why and that she said you
know she has talked with people and
heard from people who didn't do that and
then later in their uh career
they regretted that
but you can regret any decision you make
so
um
in general i'm not a big fan of nudging
people to do things by changing defaults
but i'm not really opposed either um
and um anybody else have thoughts on
uh yes
um
are we being recorded i believe we're
being streamed we should be it's a
public this is representative fellows
yes i should recognize you by name being
a little too informal here
i oppose this bill
i'm a retired state employee
and for
i was a state employee for 30 years that
entire time
um
entering a deferred
compensation plan has been an option
they told me about it the first day you
know on on the job
and people are reminded this is my
experience which is you know ended four
years ago
but
you know several times a year they would
send out emails it says the deferred
comp representative is going to be here
you can go talk to them so they totally
have this as an opportunity
the biggest reason i oppose
making it mandatory is
a deferred comp is kind of like
i believe i don't have a 401k but i
believe it's the equivalent to that
and once you put your money into that
if you want to take it out before you
get to the
you know qualified retirement age there
is a penalty right and and i one thing i
would say is calling it mandatory i
don't think i'd like to suggest is not
accurate
but but it changes it to an opt-in you
don't have to so it's not mandatory but
but i understand but this bill
makes it
shall be automatically enrolled
but then you can opt out
right when you
what if what do you think that means you
look at line 14. look at you know sally
sally i mean representative phillips
we're very aware of that's the truth of
anything if you put money in a 401k or
an ira
you can't take it out that's the same
for this exactly that's exactly right
they've ruled the irs rules apply to all
deferment plans whether they're
they're corporate or governmental or
private they're all the same
most of my retirement comes from what i
saved in my 401k i didn't get a pension
unless you went to council security
and yeah you you put the money in it
grows traditional ira you put it in you
don't pay taxes before you put it in you
don't pay tax on the gain
you can only take it out under um
if you take it out before you're 50 you
have to pay a 10 percent penalty pl plus
the amount you take out becomes taxable
income that year at the normal rates for
you
if you're over 50 you can take it out
without that penalty but of course you
still pay you pay tax whenever you take
it out
the other option i don't know if it's
available for this but a regular 401k or
an ira you can borrow money against it
but if you don't pay it back that's the
same as taking it out you end up paying
penalty in tax
i
i don't know about that borrowing option
but but state employees
are automatically
enrolled in the retirement system yes
seven percent of their well if they're
the in the employee cast class seven
percent of their salary is going into
the pension fund
if they're in class two like the
corrections officers the troopers
they pay a higher rate i don't know what
it is 11 or something 11 something like
that
so they are well covered they are not
like the general citizen who doesn't
have a pension
fund okay the only thing i'd point out
is on line 14 it does say an employee
may opt out of automatic
escalation you can opt out of the whole
thing they're opting out of that of
changing the percent of their deduction
right is there
my understanding is you can opt out of
the whole thing i don't know if that's
in i think it says i'm not sure where i
read it i um
oh oh try line 20 if an employee elects
to leave the plan within 60 days they
get their
they get their money back but if you go
beyond that really early period
you're stuck i agree it's stuck in there
on line 19 it says nothing in this
section shall limit an employee's right
to modify his or her contribution rate
as a lot so they can yeah they can put
their current contributions down to zero
but yeah they can't get the money back
yes and if they've only been in the plan
for like six months so what do they have
in the plan like sixty dollars and
they're stuck with that plan that's true
but that's an irs ruling it's not i
understand that but we're telling them
we're putting their money in certain
places representative marsh for no
reason
uh thank you
the entire
reasoning behind this bill
is that it's better off for people when
they're planning for their retirement to
put money in early and give it more time
to compound the problem with that
reasoning
is it may be wrong in the case of most
people today and the reason why is many
people today have high interest rate
loans particularly student loans that
they have to pay off first and it
in that case if you actually do the math
it's much better for them to pay off
their loans first which are at an
interest rate that exceeds the projected
rate of return of any of these
retirement accounts
first and then begin saving for their
retirement which in fact is what i did
there was a time in my life when i was
almost a million dollars in debt
so i i think that the the basic thesis
that this is trying the behavior this is
trying to encourage may not actually be
in the best interest of the people that
it's being directed to and that would be
a very good reason for us not to make
this mandatory
anybody else
representative sarah linzera thank you
i i agree um i believe that this should
uh be amended if we go forward with it
to make it optional
and uh i strongly urge folks to to
utilize something like this but again um
my issue with it is that it's their
paycheck and what they want to do with
that is up to them
and um
but i believe the intent uh may have
been just that just to urge people to to
look at the future
and things and every what everybody else
all the other representatives said today
or is very accurate i believe in uh um i
agree with them
um so i think if if we were to continue
with it again um
we make some amendment to it to make it
optional
and i just want to make certain that
something that comes after maybe what
the the state changed in the pensions in
the last couple years
that's what i've kind of
gathered from it as maybe some of the
mistakes that were made by the state and
changing that pension
that
this is sort of like a fallback plan
so um but with this bill in particular
again if we could um either kill it here
or make an amendment to make it optional
yeah i'd suggest that
the default state right now is it is
optional so there would be no point in
doing that anybody else
uh yeah i just uh
i'm actually surprised there's so much
uh opposition to the bill because
the kind of person that's gonna think
about investing as far as maybe paying
off their student loan first or
investing in another type of fund
would be the same kind of person that
could understand to opt out of this
but you know the default person that
just wants to buy beer and cigarettes
and they're just a kid
you know just to put them into something
so that you know they have money when
they retire
it it's just an opt-in i just don't see
anybody else yeah
representative grota or fellows sorry
just to respond to your question about
the prob problem they can't opt out once
the once they get past once they've been
in there for
60 days
so their money
has to sit in that fund they can shut
off the additional amount going in
but it sits there if they try to take it
out before they get to
50 60 years old
they have to pay a penalty
these funds well generally long term
you know you're going to make gains
you can lose money the value of these
funds can go down it can go down to less
and the people that this is applied to
is only state employees that are
full-time
and those people are already in the
retirement system
and seven percent of their paycheck
is their contribution to the retirement
system
so if you add two more you know two
percent or whatever on top of this
that's even more they are well
positioned
much better than the general public just
with their retirement
is there anybody here who came to uh
concerning this bill
out there okay
uh representative sanchezo
every investment you can't just take the
money back out if you make a payment to
pay down the balance of your student
loan you can't later decide to take that
back out or if you pay off some of your
house you can't ask the mortgage company
to send you that check back or any other
ira or anything else you can't get the
money back without some sort of penalty
and uh
the second thing you were saying was um
oh the current retirement program i i
mean as far as understand it it's
actually under a considerable amount of
debt
so it it may be reasonable to uh have an
alternative
and they can just opt out
it's just it's just an automatic you
know um representative grota
okay so
we are a policy
committee
so
our
decision is to whether or not this is
good policy
and
i think if i had to
[Music]
and and i what my concern with and i
think it's
representative fellow shares my concern
is that
if someone is
man it is required to
participate in the plan
and
there have they have a plan there their
desire is to opt out let's
say and they don't opt out in the
required amount of time
their funds are unavailable to them
until they retire
so i just wanna so really the policy
that this this that this committee has
to make is whether or not
requiring people i mean have a
discussion on finance is fine but i
think it's irrelevant to the cut to the
policy making it's whether or not the
committee agrees that having an employee
having the state require employees
required to
enter the stack of the state deferment
payment plan without
with the option to opt out as opposed to
the option to opt in
is that good policy
thank you that's a good point
um does anybody have anything new to say
or would anyone if not would anyone like
to make a motion
i'd like to make a motion
i'd like to make a motion of itl on
would you like to speak to your motion
representative grota right
i don't think that
this committee
should make it a policy
with all the other bills that we've
heard
on the new hampshire retirement systems
and i just want to clarify that the
retirement system is not in debt it is a
very healthy retirement system
and
we have an unfunded balance which is
so all the bills we've heard about the
opportunities for state employees to
have a retirement pension plan
that
it's best that we make a policy that
requiring to enter the tax deferment
plan
is
unfavorable
okay anybody else in the community want
to explain yes i i will say i'm in favor
of itl but for different reasons i think
i'm in favor of itl because i think that
this is promoting what is actually a bad
policy for the young people entering the
workforce uh and that it's actually in
their best financial interest to first
pay off their high interest rate loans
including student loans and then comment
saving for their retirement and
therefore to enroll them into an
optional extra retirement plan uh from
the beginning of their employment is not
in their best interest
um in a sense i don't disagree with you
um
but i think it really depends on each
person's circumstance some people have
debt some people won't
certainly if you've gone to college you
you
some people manage it without debt
especially if you do a lot through the
community college system but you're
right a lot of people do have debt so
again as i say i can argue both sides of
this one um
but that is the case for some people
certainly anyone else on the committee
okay if not what the clerk called the
role
motion to
itl yeah house bill 1563 representative
leicas
yes
excuse me
representative
representative marsh
yes
representative grota
and the clerk votes yes
okay so the motion passes and i'm
closing the
subcommittee work session on house bill
mr chair for discussion i would move
amendment
0041h
which was brought to us when the bill
i'm actually looking i have it in here
i think we got it the day that we got
i have a copy here thank you
um
what i'd well so we've got a motion um
would you speak to him as their second
actually first
my second okay
uh to speak to my motion the amendment
and the original bill
came from the new hampshire prescription
drug affordability board on which i am
an alternate member
the original bill merely wanted to
change the executive director to an
unclassified position
mostly because we felt we would not be
able to fill the position as a
classified position it having very
unique qualifications
the amendment
allows the board to not just employ an
executive director but also staff
obviously staff makes it easier for
a highly paid executive director to do
their job and it's not
prudent or
for
the highly paid executive director to do
mundane tasks like filing for instance
the the two new paragraphs uh added to
the bill by the amendment uh allow us to
have a fund to collect the fees that are
already allowed under existing
legislation to be collected um so that
we can actually pay the staff and the
executive director because that was left
out of the
original bill when this was passed some
time ago
so
this was a recommendation from the
prescription drug affordability board
and as a member i think it's my
obligation to bring it forward so that's
what i'm doing
okay um one thing i maybe i should have
gotten illegally one thing i would like
to
say that whatever we do with this
amendment um
i have some questions about whether the
board should exist at all
and um i intend to propose that we amend
it to abolish the board
so we can move forward with this
amendment
and vote it on if you like or we can
do you have the amendment no i what i
would
do is have the discussion and then we
could
vote a recommendation the committee that
would be abolished then my intent if
assuming we do that would be to go
downstairs to olas and have it drafted
and what are your thoughts and why would
you have that amendment
um
part of it there's a number of pieces
that part of it's the history of how
this came about um
i mean the bill was originally created
in 2020 with house bill 1280.
um
you know the bill that bill came out of
the house as a straightforward bill
dealing with i believe co-payments for
insulin
um it got went to the senate and then as
part of uh
their way of dealing with the whole
cobit situation which i had serious
objections to and i know some others did
they turn it into an omnibus bill by
tacking a number of uh senate bills onto
it it ended up being
something like seven different topics
when it came back to the house the house
just
concurred with the senate version so i
mean this whole thing
got no public hearing at all in the
house it was not considered by any house
committee
and so the house did not have an
opportunity to give this complicated
bill any consideration at all really
and i have some concerns about the board
looking at at the bill
i mean in effect i see it as having the
power to engage almost in price fixing
for prescription drugs purchased by
if they're not satisfied with the prices
they can arrange they can make those
unavailable to patients
um you know where they're paid through
by public payers
regardless of whatever you know their
doctor recommends
um
and then there's you know the board is
authorized
create a database collect a wide range
of information um
they can actually sell that information
which seems a little odd to me
and
you know they can force various entities
to provide that they can they are
empowered to assess a variety of fees on
quite a few different entities um
i think there's an estimate around 1700
of them or more actually
and i know there's estimates of the
amount of money ranging from probably
850k to 1.2 million and it may be a
quite a bit more than that
this amendment would create a
non-lapsing dedicated fund for the money
so basically they get to
raise and spend the money basically
pretty much without oversight of the
legislature fiscal committee government
council
as i understand it
and i also noted that the board's
permitted to deliberate in secret
they're exempt from 91a except that
decisions must be made public and i have
an issue with that
and
i understand the idea behind the board
but
the fact that there's nobody either on
the board not even on the advisory
council they're not
they can't have any representation from
drug producers or providers to provide
their view
i i'm concerned about
and i also question whether the board's
necessary and the departments of
insurance and hhs
have been collecting
you know similar prescription drug drug
information for
something over a decade
and the department of administrative
services is currently authorized to
conduct a reverse auction process to
achieve lower prices
for prescription drugs
for the health insurance plan
administered by the state and it's my
understanding they have successfully
done so already
so that's that's my reasons for uh
proposing an amendment to abolish the
board
representative marsh
thank you i would oppose efforts to
abolish the new hampshire prescription
drug affordability board i believe
that this is something that governor
sununu has supported
it's something that's being done in our
neighboring state of maine it's well
developed in the state of maryland
the the
my constituents
and my patients
really want us to do something about the
issue
of
rapidly rising prices of prescription
drugs particularly when they're rising
on drugs that have been out for a very
long time it's not new research this is
not new developments it's not troubles
in the supply chain it's just that they
have pricing power in the current
economic environment
and
this board is digging into
numerous issues in the
supply chain for prescription drugs some
of which are
extremely confusing
it's not a simple free market economy
and i think without this the new
hampshire uh consumer and and our
constituents remain at risk for
being gouged for prescription drug
prices so
i i will very much oppose a move to
repeal the prescription drug
representative
phillips ah thank you so i i have a
question i would like somebody to tell
what drugs this applies to because my
thought was it has to do with the drugs
that the state would be buying or that
would be part of the medicaid
and it's not you know
it wouldn't it wouldn't impact any costs
that i person that i would pay for drugs
my understanding is it's any uh
there's a
we've got the statute here uh
representative marsh might actually be
able to offhand give a clear answer to
because i
but it's it's
plans that are
administered under under the control of
the state so i mean
if you're not getting medical care
through any of those then no i suppose
what's that
oh sorry yes a representative of fellows
so thank you
so so the other thought when i had when
i was looking at this i i think maybe i
did the same thing you did i went to the
hhs website i found a place where they
were
collecting information about
drug prices and and it
you know it looked like a
the collection that they would get from
these pharmacies
looks like a spreadsheet with you know
each drug you had to list it and you
know what the
cost was and maybe like four or five
things it did just numbers just
spreadsheet
and that most of the work i'm wondering
if most of the work of the board is
mostly just like clerical and and
compiling the the data
representative
yes i just want to refer to the statute
here
if you look at 126 bb5 roman 4
i'll just read it so that you know it
says by november 1st 2020 and annually
thereafter the board shall report its
recommendations including prescription
drug spending targets their strategies
for optimization of the affordability of
prescription drugs for the state and all
of its residents the progress of
implementing those recommendations as
well as the annual net spending by
public payers on prescription uh
pharmaceutical products as a measure of
the efficacy of implementation of those
recommendations to date to the standing
committees of the general court with
jurisdiction over health care coverage
and insurance matters and to the
governor um i i would say based on that
charge that this is intended to address
the cost of prescription drugs not just
for people who are funded by public
okay although i
in reading it i've got it in front of me
now
i believe it's given particular powers
around
negotiating prices for drugs
purchased by public payers and in
126 bb1 the definitions uh part six it's
or roman six it says public payer means
any division of state county or
municipal government that administers a
health plan for its employees
or an association of state county or
municipal employers that administers a
health plan for its employees but i
agree that it it is charged to do
reporting on larger issues but it
doesn't happen i would agree with that
yes yeah okay thank you
i'm sorry i would be against dissolving
the board
okay thank you um we've got
on the table that's been seconded for
this um the amendment amendment uh
004041h
so
um
you know unless people want to withdraw
i'm happy to vote on the motion if
that's the chair's wish
on the amendment okay so why don't we do
that first um
the questions on adopting the amendment
zero zero four one h to house bill one
five six six
on the amendment
zero zero four one each
representative like us
no
representative san antacio
representative marsh
yes
representative grota
and the clerk
yes
okay three to three to two the uh
amendment's adopted or at least our
right will recommend that it be adopted
um
and actually i think
if we're going to follow the the
tradition if not rules for the committee
normally you ask the chairlast for their
vote
um
i'm not making a uh
i don't know that it's a motion but it's
i guess a motion that the board i mean
sorry the subcommittee recommend
that an amendment be created and adopted
to
eliminate the prescription drug
affordability board
and any further discussion on that
i'll second it you're making emotions
i'm sorry yeah sucking it okay thank you
uh mr chair may ask for a clarification
certainly uh is your motion that you uh
wish to make an amendment to repeal or
say 126
bb that's correct
uh thank you
um i believe that's all of the statute
concerning the new hampshire
prescription drug affordability board is
in there that would be correct okay i
was going to ask olas to make sure that
okay
if there's no further discussion with
representative san ontasio
yes
representative marsh
no
representative grota
clerk votes yes
any chair
yes
3-2
okay that motion is adopted um and i'm
going to close the work session on house
bill 1566
and
you